my name is Adam Bromberg I am an artist
an educator and an activist I've had
shows all over the world and all my
shows in Germany have been cancelled
I've spent the last 2 years in Palestine
photographing all the olive trees of
Palestine the oldest tree we
photographed called Al badawi is 4,500
years old I found myself accused of
being a hateful anti-semite 2 weeks
after my mother's death and my mother
was a survivor of the Holocaust so I
just buried my mother who had such
firsthand experience of the Holocaust
and came back to these liess accusations
the two times I felt most um threatened
in an existential way that is um a
commemoration that happened last year of
Crystal I was holding a sign that I made
it said Jews against fascism every
everywhere I was approached by a group
of Jews who were also there to to
commemorate Crystal KN I was physically
threatened by one of these people now
the idea of a Jew at a crystal KN
commemoration being threatened violently
threatened by another Jew and having to
seek Refuge with the German police is
one of the most ironic things I've heard
and the second time I felt most threat
was at a commemoration for the nakba
within seconds there were maybe three or
four you know very big German Riot
policemen on top of me and beat me quite
severely and handcuffed me um the fact
that a Jew from a holocaust surviving
family can Stand Accused by the state of
Germany who is or who is not an
anti-semite they should be the last
people who uh who can throw that ation
around make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer